he paid for the entire date and he
didn't expect you to have sex with him
he is a gentleman I also haven't heard
from him in a week you've gone out with
the guy four times yeah how are you not
Facebook friends with him yet
he gave us a perfect human tags how do
you not know his password please if they
books you Tigers not gonna be too
suspicious
but I responded in things it's clearly a
slow thing that is clearly avoidance she
tweets more than she breathes
oh-oh who is this who does this belong
to a human man right
Dawson's frites 76 the grinder guy keeps
rolling what do you know about her she's
training for the marathon I'm supposed
to runs on RunKeeper you see there's
like a nine point eight mile loop on the
Westside Highway
that is a creepy level of detail but
still an excellent entry point what have
all these years of being in a
relationship is stunted my personal
growth maybe I was supposed to be
someone else
I keep thinking at how did I get here
and I want you to put your number in
right there okay and then take a selfie
take a selfie got you look at that cutie
less than a mile away how about hello
before we start discussing sexual
position yay
I'm this close to walking over to your
date and showing her your text she's a
girlfriend she introduced herself to me
she knew exactly who I was she must have
stalked you online
she's probably like scrolling through
your Instagram
if this was the last time you're ever
gonna see him
what do you be okay not saying anything
you tweeted about this Twitter's public
hashtag - this [ __ ] is gonna be
trending by the end of the night
you